by the way I was supposed to do a movie
with you I was supposed to do this movie
Red Sky
I was supposed to get a rush to the guy
Dave Riggs or whatever took me up in a
MIG and we flew and I felt the g-force
and I ended up saying no last minute
do you know he's dead now
how did he die
flying someone around in one of those
planes and he took the director's
assistant with him he was a young woman
she was only 23. when was that
when did he die I think it was around
2013 and I have like like right after
the no the movie was 2007 or something
right yeah so it was after that by a
couple years
um oh my God I flew with him he was also
a career Criminal Who spent a lot of
time in sing-sing who didn't have a
pilot's license when he was flying you
because he buzzed people as a publicity
stunt in his plane on the Santa Monica
Pier who still had Burns or in the
hospital like when we were shooting a
movie this is all true oh you can you
can look it up
I flew with that guy he didn't know a
pilot's license not an active one
it was literally revoked I could have
died that day 100
holy [__] the other actors fly with him
too
I don't remember to be honest with you
it was his contribution to the movie
that he was going to be flying these you
know retired Russian Megs that was like
and he did fly them yeah
there was no accidents God
I wasn't there for that party you aren't
there for that part you were the love
interest yeah
was it fun shooting in Russia no you
didn't have any fun you cannot talk to
you about the movie really it was it was
a whole
um
here's what I will say it came out and I
haven't even seen it I've only seen the
trailer but it seems like it came out
way better than it had any right to but
it wasn't fun it wasn't fun for you it
was
um
it was dangerous and completely insane
it was the most Lawless production I've
ever been on oh my God and nobody could
kind of like save us because we were in
Russia you have to get like a work
permit to even like get into the country
like there's no there's no Union can
touch you out there like it's it was it
was really wild yeah Jesus I will tell
you some stories that will like blow
your hair back later yeah